eine absolut bemerkenswerte ansprache
eine bemerkenswerte rede vor der man
respekt haben muss weil sie so klar war
die kanzlerin hat gesagt die oster ruhe
war allein mein fehler sie hat gesagt
dieser fehler ist einzig und allein mein
fehler
die letzte verantwortung und sie hat
gesagt ich bitte die bürger um
verzeihung das sind worte die sie in
dieser pandemie und auch in anderen
krisen in dieser deutlichkeit noch nie
gewählt hat sie hat darauf hingewiesen
dass diese oster ruhe in der konsequenz
nicht umsetzbar war sie hat auf die
logistik verwiesen auf den auf die
probleme beim supermarkt sie hat gesagt
dass das ganze in dieser kürze der zeit
nicht wirklich war interessant bei dem
satz der kanzlerin um verzeihung bitten
da erinnern wir uns vor allem an jens
spahn den gesundheitsminister der vor
ein paar monaten gesagt hat wir werden
in dieser krise noch viel um verzeihung
bitten müssen also sie lehnt sich
indirekt gewollt oder nicht auch daran
an und man muss sagen sie hat danach
klar verwiesen dass es aus ihrer sicht
in dieser vorlage themen gibt mit denen
man die pandemie bekämpfen kann also da
geht es dann auch wieder um
ausgangsbedingungen
sie hat auf die mutation verwiesen und
sie hat gesagt dass der beschluss vom
montag den rahmen auch der notbremse
gibt sie hat klar sich auch an die
bürger gewendet sie hat von der großen
verunsicherung gesprochen die das ganze
ausgelöst hat und sie hat dann gesagt
dass sie diese verunsicherung die daraus
entstanden ist dass sie das zutiefst
bedauert und um verzeihung bittet eine
große ansprache der kanzlerin die ich so
in meiner zeit als politischer
korrespondent noch nicht erlebt haben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei der schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren